les yeux de Sylvie La Rochelle pétillent
encore lorsqu'elle parle aux résidents
de sa RPA mais la propriétaire de 61 ans
est fatigué la pandémie a été difficile
dans la paroisse ici il y en a trois qui
ont fermé la dernière qui est ouverte
son prochain défi installé des gicleurs
parce qu'il y en a aucun ici mais les
coups sont exorbitants
1767 et ça c'est la soumission de juin
22 fait que avec le covid tu augmentes
sur le cachera pas faudrait que je me
rendais quasiment du prix de la bâtisse
pour mettre des gicleurs au Québec il y
a encore une RPA sur trois qui n'est pas
complètement équipée de gicleur et même
si le gouvernement leur donne deux ans
de plus pour se conformer à la loi 15%
d'entre elles environ 75 établissements
risque de fermer en raison des coûts qui
ont explosé on demande aux gens du
Québec de bonifier les programmes
parce que les réseaux d'accueduc et les
puits en milieu ruraux sont aussi
problématiques il ne fournissent pas
assez de pression pour les gicleurs il
faut donc acheter des pompes agro-prix
j'ai des résidences qui m'appellent en
pleurant qui me disent j'ai un puits
donc ça va me coûter 150 000 à 200000
dollars juste pour mettre une pompe on
note réservé une enveloppe de plus de
200 millions de dollars pour pouvoir
financer l'installation des giclards
partout la tragédie de l'île verte en
2014 dans laquelle 32 années ont perdu
la vie à marquer le Québec et la
ministre responsable des Aînés étaient
mordicus au gicleur on le voit
l'installation des gicleurs c'est
fondamentale on peut pas se passer de ça
aujourd'hui et donc on va aller de
l'avant et puis il faut prendre le temps
nécessaire sauf que pour certains le
temps commence à presser et décembre
2024 c'est encore long avec la pénurie
d'employés le report inquiète vous savez
que la pénurie de main d'oeuvre c'est
qu'il y a moins de monde la nuit le soir
et les week-ends
si ça fait pas
ça va être la fin on a pas le choix
comme bain ici Pierre-Alexandre Bolduc
Radio-Canada c'est un prospère